هذه اقرب نقطه استطعنا الوصول اليها قريبا
من السد الترابي الذي انهار بفعل فيضان
نهر العاصي هذا السد كان كان يحجب مياه
النهر الى
عن هذه القريه لكن فيضان النهر بعد
الزلزال دفع بالمياه الى الحاجز الترابي
او السد الترابي فانهار بشكل سريع وانطلقت
المياه الى بيوت القريه ستظهر الكاميرا
الطائره ستظهر حجم الكارثه التي تعرضت لها
هذه القريه حيث اجتمع الزلزال ومياه النهر
فدمر الزلزال العديد من البيوت اكثر من 20
بيت في هذه القريه وادى الى تصدع الحاجز
الترابي او السد الترابي ثم غرقت بيوت
القريه في المياه واضطره سكان هذه البيوت
الى المغادره خلال ساعات الليل ليس ذلك
فقط بل ان هذه القريه تحوي على مخيم
للنازحين مثل البلدات التي تقع على خط
الحدود السوريه التركيه سكان هذا المخيم
اضطروا ايضا
للخروج من هذا المخيم ليستقروا في مخيمات
اخرى بعيدا او في منطقه اعلى من هذا
المكان نهر العاصي يمر بجوار هذه القريه
ويظهر هنا مفارقه الحياه والموت ان يكون
النهر سببا للحياه او سببا للموت وخلال
تاريخهم استطاع سكان المنطقه تطويع مياه
النهر لكن زلزال دمر حساباتهم واستطاعت
المياه اخيرا مياه نهر العاصي ان تصل الى
بيوتهم واشد ما يخاف منه السكان ان تدمر
البيوت لان هذه البيوت مبنيه على التراب
كما اخبرنا سكان القريه فهنا لا توجد
منطقه صخريه صهيب الخلف الجزيره من بلده
تلول ريف ادلب